my colleague from the NFL media group
was just who's does great work all the
time and a lot of the conversations that
he has been having on on NFL Network on
the matters of the real world and how
they do relate to the NFL Jim Trotter
here on the Rich Eisen show how are you
sir I'm good how you doing I'm doing
fine I'm doing fine
I guess let's just jump in with both
feet here Jim I saw Vic Fangio trending
this morning and I didn't know why then
I clicked on it and I realized why what
did you make of his comment this morning
saying that he doesn't see racism at all
in the NFL Jim I think as I read the
entirety of his his comments because
rather than just rely on the headline I
wanted to try and get the full context
and if you go back and you look at
everything he said during that press
conference it was clear he was speaking
out against police brutality and all
those sorts of things but I think in
terms of him talking about the NFL being
a meritocracy at least as I read it he
was talking about more on the field than
anywhere else because if you look at the
NFL beyond the field you can't say it's
a meritocracy and you know that's why
the league statement that it put out
after George Floyd's death you know rang
hollow with so many people because when
you look at it you have 32 teams they're
only four head coaches of color you have
32 teams there are only two black
general managers you have 32 teams and
yet there has never in the history 100
year history of this league been a black
club president or black majority owner
when you go to the league office if you
include the CEO there are 12 executive
vice presidents there are only two
people of color when you look at the
newsroom and a league that's 70% black
the two men making decisions in the
newsroom are both white so if the league
is talking about how it is about racial
equality and whatnot the numbers seem to
reflect otherwise so there's work to be
done there
Jim Trotter here on the Rich Eisen show
speaking to players as much as you have
over the last 48 hours 70 to 90 hours
what are you hearing Jim Oh everything
that you're hearing and everything that
you're seeing on social media and on TV
it's it's interesting you know the one
thing I've been trying to get at is what
makes 2020 different from 2016 when
Colin Kapernick first took a knee and
there were so many people who were
afraid to demonstrate with him and
particularly white players who were
afraid to publicly demonstrate with him
or to even speak out on the issue and so
we do what we call press coverage it's a
weekly column where the riders from the
digital group we get together and we
pick a topic and we talked about it and
I just asked why don't we talk about
what's going on in the country right now
and address why we were hearing Carson
Wentz speak out we're hearing Ryan
Tannehill Derek Carr Joe burrow even on
the college level Trevor Lawrence and we
went into it and what's interesting is I
finally got a response from Derek Carr
yesterday when I asked why are you
speaking out now and you didn't four
years ago and you know he was very
vulnerable and he was very honest with
it and said you know he had always been
taught that when there were
controversial issues like that where
people were so polarized you keep your
head down and you just move forward but
based on the last two years in
particular it's just been heavy on his
heart and he just felt that it was time
now he felt compelled to speak out on
these things and you know that that
regardless of what the politics are
regardless of what anyone else is going
to say and it's funny I hear people
comment on my social media and say well
he's four years too late or they said in
the other and my response is I don't
think you're ever too late to do the
right thing you know paraphrasing Martin
Luther King so I applaud him and I
applaud the others you know who have
spoken out and hopefully it helps lead
to change more quickly than it might
have otherwise
is it possible part of this too is just
again the that they were you know the
only video back in 2016 was if
Kaepernick taking a knee
and the president referring to NFL
players his sons of [ __ ] and now the
video in 2020 is of knees on necks and
jogging african-american men getting
shot dead in the streets could that be
part of it to you no rich no question
video is powerful and we can go back to
too many instances even for instance in
domestic violence where when you have
video it takes it to a whole nother
realm so of course that's a big factor
but for anyone to act like they were
unaware that these things were going on
when folks have been demonstrating and
protesting not just the last four years
but long before that
I think it's disingenuous at best I
think conscious decisions were made in
my mind to say you know what either I'm
not going to get involved or it's not my
fight and I'm just going to choose to
move on with my daily life and that's
the unfortunate part I just wonder if
more people had been receptive to the
message that of why Colin Kaepernick was
protesting back in 2016 might some of
these killings that we have seen in the
last four years have been avoided and
obviously there's no way to know that
completely but I can't help but wonder
that so again I'm what I'm trying to do
is not get so focused back on 2016 but
now see okay we are at this point in
time what can we do going forward and
you know my thing is look because you
know we had a discussion with Kurt one
or two days ago about what can white
people do who really want to make a
difference in this and I think number
one you have to be willing to listen
number two you have to be willing to
educate yourself and number three you
have to be intentional in saying it's
not just enough to say this isn't okay
but to identify the root problem here
and then say I'm going to be committed
to action to change this and really
that's the only way I think we make
change in this country well I've got an
qualms Bolden on the show tomorrow
and he is definitely about the the
action and the active word and and
identifying bills that need to be
brought up in state houses or bills that
need to be repealed in state houses and
so on and so forth what what what is the
nfl's relationship with him his
organization other organizations that
players have put together to actually
put some of the statements that you said
that in many parts rang hollow to put
some action behind it
what are you hearing on - well as you
know the NFL and the Players Coalition
work together on issues and they have
the inspired change initiative and the
Players Coalition has made some
tremendous strides and we don't hear
about them because they're not
headline-grabbing you know those sorts
of things there but but the things that
are critical in terms of addressing
concerns and issues in minority
communities in particular whether it's
it's changing in Michigan changing the
the requirement for or preventing minors
from being prosecuted under the age of
18
whether it's restoring voting rights to
two convicted felons after they've come
out and been out for X number of years
and now they have a chance to
participate in our electoral process
whether it's not whether it's out you
know fighting for the clean slate Act
which wipes away or seals I should say
criminal records for so many people or
whether it's fighting for word to get
more money you know infused into public
school systems to help with education in
disadvantaged communities they've done a
lot of great work and I think they're
going to continue to do great work and
now some people will say well much of
that money came from owners who just
wanted to buy the players silence and
stop them from demonstrating and there's
no way for me or anyone else to say what
was actually in the heart of these men
and women who committed that money to
these projects all I know is that that
money is helping to make a difference in
these communities and and that's what we
have to be focused on Jim Trotter
vennett's on network in Ethel media
group here on the Rich Eisen show my
colleague a few more minutes left with
you sir Oh what what happened with the
Rooney rule and the Opera in the attempt
- as we were reading put more teeth into
it more incentivizing that involved
draft choices what was actually put on
the table and what was actually done
over the last two weeks Jim well you
know rich a lot of that has been
completed two things have been conflated
number one the Rooney rule was separate
from the resolutions that were being
presented to the owners the Rooney rule
is something that's instituted by the
league office it does not require a vote
of the owners so the league can make
those changes on its own and it did and
it changed the requirements now where
you have to interview a minimum of two
minority candidates for any GM or head
coaching position it also said that now
teams must also apply the Rooney rule to
the coordinator position which is huge
because as you know many owners want
head coaches who have at least
coordinator experience and and and what
this will do all right let me backtrack
I should also say there was another
enhancement there where the league said
now that let me get this right the
league said that that teams will no
longer be allowed to block assistant
coaches from interviewing for
coordinator positions that was a
resolution that was voted on by the
owners it's separate from the Rooney
rule that's huge because as I said many
owners want head coaches who have
coordinator experience this should get
minorities into the pipeline as
coordinators as it relates to the
incentive part of this thing where they
talked about improving Draft positions
in the third round for teams that hired
minority GM's or head coaches that was
something that a lot of people just
weren't comfortable with at this point
both in terms of ownership and even in
the minority community the minority
coaches I talked to did not like that
idea because one they felt like it was
bad for the league because it looked
like you had to bribe owners simply to
hire a person of color and secondly they
felt it put a a Scarlet Letter on their
chest and that the only reason they got
the position was because of the color of
their skin now having said that I can
tell you I talked to a couple of former
minority head coaches who told me look
we don't care what the what the means
are to get that opportunity we just need
to get our foot in the door and show we
can do the job and hopefully that will
allow us to bring along other people
well I had Andy Reid on on my show the
other day Jim and asked him about Eric
the enemy and why you know basically
what gives right I mean we anybody who's
been around the league knows who the
enemy is and knows that he he suffers no
fools
I mean we've so we saw some video I
think on NFL gameday morning a few years
ago where he was just given the business
to Adrian Peterson I think in his 2000
yard season or fresh off it right I mean
he just doesn't care who you are he's
gonna coach you hard
he is also now a super bowl-winning
offensive coordinator prior to that
leading up he was clearly an offensive
coordinator for a team that was
Superbowl worthy and he stant had a
league MVP a quarterback right exactly
yes there's that too and Andy didn't
mention racism or color of skin or
Rooney rule he mentioned that that that
people hire coaches when when guys like
him are are going on playoff runs and
it's tough to to get Adam or get him to
interview or that was essentially his
implication that the the problem was the
schedule and and allowing guys like him
to to be interviewed or or wait is
essentially what what was I was
gathering I wonder what your thoughts
are on a subject like that and I hope
I'm sorry and and I know that Andy
behind the scenes has been pushing very
hard for Eric to get an opportunity and
it's been asking people what do I need
to do what can I do those sorts of
things because he believes he's
deserving of that opportunity but the
reality is if you believe that someone
is worth waiting on you wait on them I
just feel that way look at look at how
many times teams particularly let's say
a couple of years ago Indianapolis with
Josh McDaniels they knew who they want
before he was his playoff run was over
so I don't I don't buy that it's timing
or the schedule or anything like that
what I hear from these minority coaches
is look there is a problem here in terms
of owners comfort level with people who
don't look like them don't share the
same social backgrounds it's a more
cultural background to them but I would
go to I would go to take it one step
further rich I think it's what Tony
Dungy said to me last summer when I was
working on a story and he said that NFL
owners simply don't know how to hire
head coaches and we point out because
what happens every hiring cycle the
first question we hear from people is
who are the hot candidates and owners
are guilty of that too
and what they don't do first is
established what are they looking for in
a head coach do you want someone with
past experience or someone who's fresh
do you want someone old or someone
younger you want someone from office
defense or special teams do you want
someone who's hands-on or do you want
someone who do you want someone who's
more charismatic or do you want someone
who's more laid-back understated all of
these questions should be answered
before you ever even get to the point of
saying who should we consider to be our
head coach and if you haven't done that
that reflects why since 2000 we've had
an average of nearly seven head coaches
changing every year you're talking about
a quarter of the workforce among head
coaches changing every year since 2000
so as an honor doesn't that tell you
that your business model is flawed if
you're making those changes that often
so I would say it's I would go one step
further and say it all starts at the top
and it starts with owners and the league
has done everything is trying to do
everything it can to address this issue
because it is not a goodly a good look
for the league but unfortunately the
league does not hire head coaches and if
there's one thing we know about owners
to this point is they're pretty damn
good at firing but they're not very good
at hiring Jim Trotter here on the Rich
Eisen show I don't mean to laugh but
you're kind of spot on right there
before I let you go what are you hearing
about
what Adam Schefter former colleague at
the NFL Media Group is reporting that it
looks like training camp is what the
league is looking at for getting players
back into facilities and physically
together and that that that would be
significant obviously having no on-field
practices in the spring is something
that everyone eventually can deal with
if we're talking about let's just get
focused on a playing season but what are
you hearing about the sands running
through the hourglass on the NFL's
opportunity to plan for a season here
you know rich even as far back as a
month ago that was what I was hearing
from the owners that I had talked to as
they felt that the first time the
players were going to get together was
in all likelihood going to be training
camp in a best-case scenario so that
doesn't surprise me at all you know
we've been told as you know not to
speculate on all of this I'm not going
to speculate but I do believe that that
one thing the NFL has on its side is
time and that it can it can sit back and
observe what happens with the other
leagues that are looking to start now
you know we've heard that baseball
ideally would like to have a spring
training this month quote-unquote and
then start a season in July and I think
that if that were to happen I think the
NFL would be able to see are there any
hiccups what were the pros and cons any
issues and I think if there are no
issues there or or let's say the NBA
starting up and I think to them the
message is we we we go as planned if
they're hiccups then I think obviously
they would have to use contingency plans
but my expectation at this point barring
something dramatic happening is that we
will have training camp on time and the
season will proceed as scheduled I don't
know what it'll look like right I don't
know if that means pants or not but I
believe it'll start as scheduled well I
mean you know I you're seeing you
mentioned baseball their collective
bargaining agreement comes up after the
next playing season you're already
beginning to see you know conversations
between the two sides right now that are
preparing for that
how huge was it that the NFL got their
CBA done just before the pandemic it or
just as no question no question it was
huge I can't imagine what those
discussions would be like right now you
know with everything that's going on and
this climate in you know in a word huge
because you're seeing right now what's
going on with baseball and it's Union
and the conversations you're hearing are
absolutely you know hackles up based on
the multi-billion dollar argument that's
coming and the fact that the league and
I know many players were not happy that
that deal got passed ratified etc and it
just couldn't be any bigger that cuz for
everyone to come together if if things
do need to change and modify it
obviously big that there's a 10-year
deal that's on that signed and hammered
out what are you just are you hearing
anything about protocols you hearing
anything about like again I'm reading
about n95 masks being put on face masks
and things of that nature to to try and
mitigate whatever community spread could
happen should should the players get out
there are you hearing anything on that
front yeah Ritchie here a lot of things
and and I'm hesitant to talk about any
of it because I don't know that any of
it will come to fruition but people are
speculating about a lot of things and
the one thing I can't say is that no one
really knows I mean everyone I talk to
from owners down it's just sort of well
maybe this well maybe this or maybe that
but nobody knows and so I think it would
be irresponsible of me to kind of just
throw this stuff out there right without
knowing that that any of it has a chance
to come into fruition GM I appreciate
the time is there anything you want to
you know pass along to any of the
information or that you've gleaned from
I'm looking as we're talking right now
and at all network is Riera ng I believe
you chatted with Chris long and Richard
Sherman if I'm not mistaken correct
yeah and Steve Steve wash and myself
spoke to the two of them and the
part of that roundtable is going to air
tonight and I think at the risk of
self-promotion here I should there's an
eye on Jim don't worry about it that's
not my philosophy you wanted Chris you
ready tell Jim Trotter what my
philosophy at NFL networking before has
been torrid tell them if not you who if
not now when do you have the floor Jim
what is going on for people to know
about tonight 4 p.m. total access NFL
network 4 p.m. Pacific we've got a round
table
Steve washing myself with Richard
Sherman and Chris long and I think the
conversation is definitely worth your
time also go to nfl.com and we've got a
press coverage column where mike silver
Judy Batista Jeffrey Chitty and myself
discuss whether the significance of so
many white players now speaking up about
social injustice as opposed to four
years ago when so many were silent
fantastic appreciate it I love Richard
Sherman man I love every word he says I
just I just what one of the last times I
saw him I didn't think I saw him at the
Super Bowl but it was like two years ago
he's been on many times it was after he
blew out his Achilles on that Thursday
night game Jim and he already had his
leg up on the roller you know that guys
have when they have an Achilles problem
and just my default words when I say
someone when I see somebody or talk to
him is how you doing and I just said to
him I'm like hey man how you doing and
he kind of gave me this look like how
the hell do you think I'm doing you know
like I've been an idiot right there with
you the same way you know and you
realize just how dumb you sound or not
speaking for myself as you say if that
default greeting I know and I just think
he kind of gave me that look you know
like and I should know months of rehab
career in question contract up how the
hell do you think I'm doing you know and
there's nothing to do with being a dad
and a father you know husband didn't all
the pressures that come with that being
in the NFL I just sat there and I'm like
what a dumbass and I went up to like Irv
I'm like would you mind going to him
afterwards when you see him just make
sure he understands I'm not a total
complete [ __ ] in
my nose you know we all know that
written I appreciate that
again I look forward at Chris long is a
great human too and so are you and Steve
watch I look forward to seeing the rest
of that conversation tonight on NFL
Network thanks for the call Jim well I
appreciate you having me you got at Jim
Trotter at Jim Trotter underscore NFL
follow him on Twitter all his great
information right here on the Rich Eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here